welcome to the video series of
neurotransmitters
this is the first video and in this
video we'll look at the glutamate
glutamate is one type of amino acid
and in our nervous system glutamate can
work like a neurotransmitter
generally glutamate receptors are
present in the postsynaptic neuron and
glutamate
is working as an excitatory
neurotransmitter
in several synapses
across cns and pns
about 60 to 70 percent of all the
synapses present in the brain
are glutamatergic in nature
now glutamate synapses can be found in
central nervous system as well as in the
peripheral nervous system
but let me tell you too much glutamate
is also bad
because it can lead to
excited
that means hyper excitability of the
brain
and this lead to an excitation
inhibition imbalance in the brain which
can lead to several diseases like
epilepsy
it can even lead to a death of the
neuron but before going to that
extremity let's talk about
glutamate biosynthesis in the neuron and
utilization
then let's talk about glutamate
receptors and their kinetics and where
we can find glutamatergic synapses and
how it works
so stay tuned till the end of this video
and use a headphone for a better sound
quality
so glutamate biosynthesis and
utilization is a complex procedure let's
try to understand this procedure by
looking at the synapse so here is a
glutamatergic synapse you can see the
presynaptic neuron terminal here and the
postsynaptic dendritic terminal here
and in pink you can see a glia nearby
all these players are important to
understand this process
now presynaptic action potential reach
the synaptic turning terminal which lead
to the release of glutamate into the
synaptic cleft
now this glutamate would bind to the
glutamate receptors present in the post
synapse
question is where do glutamate come from
so glutamate comes from
glutamine
now where does glutamine come from
anyway glutamine is converted to
glutamate by the help of mitochondrial
enzyme glutamines
glutamine is indeed supplied by the glia
so glia supply glutamine which
gets into the presynaptic terminal with
specific transporters and that gets
converted to glutamate with the help of
glutamines enzyme
once glutamate is synthesized it gets
packaged into synaptic vesicles
with the help of v-glute
transporters or vesicular glutamate
transporters
and ultimately these synaptic vesicles
are released into the post-synapse
now once it's present in the synaptic
cleft glutamate doesn't stay for long
time
it gets reuptaken by the glia and neuron
with the help of excitatory amino acid
transporters
now inside the glia glutamate gets
converted to glutamine again
with the help of enzyme glutamine
synthetase
and that glutamine is again supplied
back to the presynaptic terminal for
further glutamate biosynthesis
alternatively a small proportion of
glutamate is directly uptaken into the
synaptic terminal as well
now this complicated stepwise procedure
is known as the glutamate cycle
and that's what keeps our excitatory
synapses going
the glutamate synapse is one of the
excitatory synapses there are many other
but in this video let's focus on
glutamate and how they work
at a synaptic level
in order to understand that we need to
understand glutamate receptor and their
subtypes
glutamate receptors are broadly divided
into two categories ionotropic glutamate
receptors and metabotropic glutamate
receptors
under ionotropic glutamate receptors we
can see ampa receptors kinetic receptors
and nmd receptors all these nomenclature
are done based on the agonist
of these ion channels
now there are metabotropic receptors
which are specific uh g protein coupled
receptors and they work using several
second messengers and intermediate
players
and these are referred as
m glu r
if you wanted details about metabotropic
and ionotropic receptor and how they
work you can quickly get it in the eye
button
now
in short ionotropic receptors that are
ligand-gated ion channel are very fast
in terms of their action so it's just
ligand binding to the channel which
leads to channel opening and influx of
the ion so it would rapidly depolarize
or change the potential of a neuron
whereas metabotropic receptors
are slow in nature because they have to
generate intermediate players
intermediate players would then
coordinate with each other to bring out
the cellular response
the first type of
ionotropic glutamate receptor that we
are going to talk about is ampa
receptors
ampa receptors are found in the post
synapse in the glutamatergic neurons
when the presynaptic action potential
reach the nerve terminal it releases
glutamate into the cleft and let's see
what happens in the post synapse in the
post synapse we would have ampa
receptors which binds to glutamate and
allows the influx of cations inside the
neuron
so cations flow inside and it leads to a
positive potential in the membrane so
the membrane becomes more positive which
leads to a post synaptic potential or
postsynaptic current
in order to understand the kinetics of
these kind of receptors we can look at
their physiological properties by
electrophysiological recordings in a
patch clamp settings in a whole cell
mode if we
hold it in a voltage clamp method we can
stabilize the voltage at a particular
defined voltage and we can look at the
current like here
so if we hold amber receptors as at
minus 70 millivolts we would see a
inward current
and you see the current
differs with the voltage
and you can see as the voltage increases
towards more positive side the direction
of the current is reversed
another way of understanding this is to
plot a iv plot or
cur or current versus voltage plot or gv
plot or conductance versus voltage plot
anyway for ample receptors this plot
would look like
this
and the gv plot would look like a flat
line
by looking at the plot we can understand
there is inward direction current at
negative voltage where there is outward
direction current at positive voltage
and the reversal potential is zero
now looking at the gv plot we can
understand by changing voltage there is
no change in the conductance its kind of
like a flat line so ampa receptors are
kind of independent to voltage and that
is expected because an ampa receptors
the conductance of the ampa receptor
does not depend on voltage because they
are
ligand-gated io channels they are not
voltage-gated ion channels right that's
why their conductance is voltage
independent
anyway
let's talk about the kinetic receptors
just like ampa kinet would be a
ligand-gated ion channel they would
conduct sodium and potassium
now these single channel current is
slightly
more than ampa receptors the single
channel current is
single channel conductance is actually
more than 20 picosecond
whereas for amp it is 10 to 15
picosecond
rise and decay time
for the postsynaptic potential generated
by kinetic receptors are slightly slower
compared to ampa but not as slow as the
nmd receptors that we are going to talk
about next
now nmda receptors are iron ligand-gated
ion channels but slightly different than
the
other ones so in the postsynaptic
terminal there is amp receptor which
lead to
cation influx upon binding to glutamate
and this cation influx
is uh making the membrane more positive
but the nmd receptor works in a
different principle
so when there is a cationic influx
through the ampa receptor at the same
potential lmd receptor might not be
active
because nmd receptor has a magnesium
block so imagine
the initial stage where the
inside of the membrane is still somewhat
negative at this point magnesium block
is there in the nmda channel's pore
that's why none of the cations can go
through the nmda receptor but after
conduct conductance of ampa receptor for
a long time what would happen is the
inside would become positive
and the positive potential inside would
repel the magnesium ion away from the
nmd receptors channel which would allow
the influx of cations through the nmd
receptor to the post synapse and
these cations are not only sodium or
potassium calcium
also get in through the through this
nmda receptor
let's talk about the
electrophysiological properties of the
nmda receptor
again we are going to use a voltage
clamp recording so at negative potential
you can see the line is pretty much flat
so at minus 70 millivolt there is almost
no current minus 50 there is a minuscule
current
if we go closer like minus 10 which
which means the
membrane potential is bit more positive
compared to the resting membrane
potential which is minus 65 millivolt we
see some amount of inward current
and then at positive potential we do see
a current whose amplitude is much more
than the earlier ones
in any way we can plot a iv plot that we
have seen before for the nmda receptor
as well
and iv plot shows that it is
kind of voltage dependent
and now at
a potential which is
low
there is no current
a potential which is more than minus 50
and in between minus 50 and 0 there is
some amount of minuscule inward current
and the outward current is at
positive voltages
looking at the gv plot we can understand
that there is a voltage dependence in
terms of the conductance of the nmda
receptor
so almost there is no conductance at
negative voltage
at the positive voltage again there is
no uh correlation between voltage
increase or conductance but there is
some amount of conductance at positive
voltage
now let us try to understand this iv
plot
using this analogy so in this part of
the iv plot
the magnesium block is still there
that's why the cations cannot get in
whereas this part which is highlighted
in the curve you can see at this point
of time the magnesium block is kind of
repelled
and that is why there is influx of
cation through the nmda receptor
now as per summary
we looked at the nmd receptors reversion
potential from the graph we can say it
is zero millivolt
it conducts sodium potassium calcium and
single channel conductance for nmd
receptor is 50 picosecond so it give
rise to sustained currents compared to
ampa or kinate ampa and kyanet shows
very fast opening and closing kinetics
whereas nmda shows
fast opening but sustained or delayed
closing kinetics
now nmd receptors are known as
coincidence detector that means they
detect the coincidence between pre and
the postsynaptic activity
it detects the synchrony between pre and
post synapse let me tell you how
nmda receptor blockade has been shown
to block potentiation
so what is potentiation so this is how a
normal synapse would look like here you
can record from the
post synapse and stimulate the
pre-synapse so obviously as expected you
would see there is a
postsynaptic potential you can see like
this
now you do a hundred hertz tetanic
stimulation
and then record from the same synapse
now again if you give the same amount of
current as before
instead of getting same amplitude of the
response now one get a augmented
response or a boosted response
this is known as synaptic potentiation
if this potentiation lasts for long this
is known as long-term potentiation
another way is to plot
the slope of these post-synaptic
potentials
and compare it over time
so just after this tetanic stimulation
you can see the slope has increased and
it stays increased for long time
in simple words this is known as
long-term potentiation
fun fact is if we block nmda receptor
from an by a pharmacological agent one
can see
even after 100 hertz stimulation there
is no
potentiation of the synapses that means
nmd receptor is really important for
regulating synaptic strength
nmda receptor blockage lead to
behavioral defects in mouse
there is a there is a particular
behavioral task known as maurice water
maze where the mouse has to find a
hidden platform in the tub and they
locate this platform with some kind of
landmarks so these are visual landmarks
with some training mouse can do this
task very nicely as seen in the control
so they directly go to the quadrant
where there is a visual landmark and
where there is a hidden platform but
when nmda receptor is blocked this
particular task is totally messed up by
the mouse so they cannot do it anymore
that means nmda receptors are associated
with memory formation
nmda receptors are ionotopic glutamate
receptors
and we looked at
that these receptors are found in
glutamatergic synapses they are
ligand-gated ion channels they regulate
synaptic strength and they are involved
in memory formation
now let's talk about
the uh
the metabotropic glutamate receptors
sorry it's written as muscarinic
acetylcholine receptors but imagine
these are metabotropic glutamate
receptors
so metabotropic glutamate receptors bind
with glutamate
they lead to
several
cellular events in this case they lead
to a gq coupled signaling which lead to
the activation of phospholipase c
that indeed activates second messengers
like
diacylglycerol and ip3
all these second messengers can lead to
cascade of events interesting cascade of
intracellular events
so group 1 mlrs
such as mglu r1 mgr5
use this kind of operation paradigm
whereas
gi coupled receptors are used
by several other classes of imbuers they
inhibit adenylate cycles adrenaline
cycles is an enzyme that generates
cyclic amp from atp
and
this particular
activity is blocked by gi coupled signal
and that kind of in turn
regulate how much of ionic influx would
be there through a cyclic nucleotide
gated ion channel and this kind of
activity is done by group 2 m gluers
such as imbuer 2 and 3 just to name a
few
so as per summary we have looked at
biosynthesis and packaging of glutamate
glutamate into the synaptic vesicle
we looked at how glutamate this
glutamate works and how glutamate
receptors work in the post synapse we
looked at the electrophysiological
properties of the glutamate receptors
we looked at how they regulate synaptic
strength
and we compare their
electrophysiological properties in terms
of iv and gv plot
so
and lastly we looked at some of these
receptors such as nmda receptors are
involved in memory formation and
synaptic plasticity if you want detailed
explanation of long-term potentiation
synaptic plasticity all of these are
linked in the i button
get notes and flash cards
in my facebook page you can also follow
us on instagram to download these
amazing flash cards which would help in
your preparation all the links are in
the description you can support my
channel using patreon bmupi app or you
can directly support using the super
thanks option which is present in the
bottom right corner of any video you can
contribute using paytm paypal or upi or
even internet banking
so
show me your support and show some love
don't forget to like share and subscribe
if you wish to connect you can get all
my social media handles in the
description you can also follow the nerd
medic channel for exclusive medical
content
as usual don't forget to like share and
subscribe